Speaker 1: as we continue to follow Joe Biden.
His approval rating declined recently and
his accomplishments and as we continue to
close in on the start of the twenty twenty
two midterm election, it's hard to deny that
the biggest political question in terms of
the next six to seven years of American politics
is the question of whether Donald Trump will
run for president in twenty, twenty four.
We can pretend that there are other, bigger
questions because we would like to believe
that the question of Trump is over, but it's
not the case.
Trump won under unusual political circumstances
in 2016 and then lost under a relatively rare
situation in twenty twenty where an incumbent
president loses reelection that it's not a
common thing.
It happened eight or 10 times in American
politics, but typically when presidents run
for reelection, they win.
Trump's base seems as committed as ever to
him.
He's been doing rallies.
He says he's going to soon be doing rallies
and key election states like Iowa.
And over the weekend, we heard from not one
but two Trump insiders, his former strategist
Jason Miller, and perpetual brownnosing Republican
Congressman Trump suck up Jim Jordan.
We heard from both of them.
Trump is almost certainly running in twenty
twenty four.
And Jim Jordan even saying he's about to announce
any day.
So let's get right into the clips.
Here is Jason Miller appearing on a channel
or show called Cheder News says that the odds
are ninety nine or one hundred percent that
Donald Trump runs in twenty twenty four.
The likelihood President Trump runs again
in twenty twenty four.
Speaker 2: I would say somewhere between 99
and 100 percent, I think he's definitely running
in 20 24, had a good conversation with him
last night and to go see him in another couple
of days here, he has not said the magical
words to me, but if you talk to him for a
few minutes, it's pretty clear that he's running.
And I think the just what we've seen unfold
in Afghanistan recently has really just emboldened
that.
Speaker 1: So that's Jason Miller.
And then Congressman Jim Jordan says Trump
is, quote, about ready to announce.
This is video once again from Lauren Winzer.
She's been doing great work in this video.
Lauren pretends to be a Republican.
And check out what Jim Jordan says.
And we're going to have it from two angles
for you here.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
He's going to run again.
He said yesterday he's about to announce that
while this great I is really bad, I think
really bad.
Well, thank you for coming.
Yeah, he's going to run again.
I talked to him yesterday.
He's not ready to announce that.
Well, this is great, A.J.
I got to tell you, my friend is really bad.
I think.
OK, well, I want to thank you for coming.
Speaker 1: So Jordan says Trump's going to
run again.
I know it.
I just talked to him yesterday.
He's about ready to announce now.
They could both be wrong.
They could both be knowingly lying because
there's been a decision made that it's a good
strategy for someone to claim that Donald
Trump is running or likely running even when
he is, I don't know.
But more and more things are pointing that
way for sure.
Now, as I've said before, I know that this
is horrifying in terms of what it means for
the country.
But if Donald Trump does run and is the Republican
nominee in 2024, he has a really good shot
at winning based on what's going on today.
Things can change, but based on what's going
on today, I don't know that I see Joe Biden
defeating Trump in a rematch.
This is you know, people will write to me,
they'll say, David, you're poisoning the well.
Now I just tell you things the way I see them
right now.
I don't know that I see Biden defeating Trump
in a rematch.
If Biden doesn't run and it's Comilla, as
I've outlined before, I don't know that I
see Comilla defeating Donald Trump.
This is just me being real.
And of course, us knowing this and getting
together around it could prevent it from happening.
But my preference is to soundly defeat Trumpet's
in the midterms so that Trump hopefully sees
this is not looking good for me.
All of my strongest followers are.
Many have been defeated and chooses not to
run to avoid the embarrassment of another
loss.
If we think of 2022 as a sort of referendum
on Trump ism and all of them lose, you know,
Matt Gates, Jim Jordan, Marjorie Taylor Green,
Bobert Cawthorn, they likely won't all lose.
But if a bunch of them lose, that might be
the signal that convinces Donald Trump not
to run.
So is Jim Jordan a known liar?
And he might be lying here, of course.
Sure.
Is Jason Miller a known liar?
Absolutely.
In his professional and personal life, from
what we've what we've heard.
But lots of signs point to Trump running.
Now, here's the counterpoint.
When I was on Michael Cohen's show, Michael
Cohen, of course, Trump's former lawyer, Michael
Cohen, said he doesn't think Trump runs in
order to avoid the shame of losing again.
But that's sort of what I'm saying.
Also, if Trump becomes convinced that he will
lose.
I don't think Trump will run.
I think we just don't know that yet in the
sense that the 2022 midterms are going to
be our signal about whether Trump is likely
to do well in 2024 or not.
Either way, I believe that if Donald Trump
runs, the GOP won't stand in his way in terms
of the primary.
You'll have some challenges, but they won't
be serious and the party won't get behind
the challengers.
But a disastrous 20 22 for Trump ism may be
what gets Trump to say, you know what?
I'm not going to get involved because the
risk of humiliation is too high.
Let me know what you think.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is an
independent media program, we don't have,
you know, MSNBC, Phil Griffin telling me what
to do or say or whatever the case may be.
Rupert Murdoch, if you can imagine, we really
are funded directly by folks like you and
you can sign up for a membership at Join Pakman
Dotcom.
We do an extra show every day for our members
and you can use the coupon code better.
Twenty one to save off of the cost of a membership.
Look forward to seeing you on the bonus show
today.